[Musique]
par les enfants mon
patron mes deux petits amis ont l'air
bien calme ce soir j'espère que nicolas
a bien pris ses médicaments ajouté sans
voix mon cher petit nicolas je lui
apportais d'un flore n'oublie pas que tu
n'es pas malade toi nounours et que tu
ne dois pas prendre de médicaments je
préfère me soigner avec du miel patron
ma chère petite fiole europe
[Musique]
c'est tout comme à mon petit frère me
faites aux doutes aux radios loup fait
au delà mon petit frère cet audit aura
du lourd
maman étant qui fait des gâteaux à pas
et en bas qui fait du chocolat
et tout doux cola mon petit frère fait
au doctorat du loup fait dodo cola mon
petit frère fait odorat du lot si tu es
mignon tard à des bonbons si tu ne dors
pas tu n'auras pas fait de joe cole à
mon petit frère 7 août aura du loup fait
doux tout comme mon petit frère fait
dodo tu auras du lot
bonsoir l'oesophage
ne fait pas trop de bruit en hausse
nicolas s'est endormi comment vas tu
pour combien il sait bien laisser
soigner demain il sera tout à fait guéri
il pourra se lève et je lui ai apporté
quelques flore merci j'ai lui donnerait
pas matin et toi mon nounours on a
remporté que trois glands me reçut vais
pas quelques médicaments
qui n'a pas très bonne mine kg tu
trouves ou quelques petites pilules
qu'elle ferait le plus grand bien non au
public tu préfères va être un petit air
charisme ou une bonne petite friction me
donne une autre mur si tu n'es dope à
dallas non je suis bien portants là tu
fais pas de sirop nous
dommage
c'était un délicieux sierro on y est
[Musique]
je crois que tout pape rebelles
d'un grand farceur admis ne nous
conduit la jette à la lumière
[Musique]
alors nounours
et tue tous oui je tousse
j'ai dû prendre froid patron rentrant
vite
je vais me soigner avec du miel oui mon
bon nounours banni les enfants ou
fêtes de bourg
[Musique]
oh